the journey to Cape Horn begins on a
ferry that leaves Punta Dennis Chile
once a week Bruce on the bow we have the
cruise and the smoke Islands
it's a 30-hour Voyage to the wild South
which unlike North America's Wild West
is still Wild
starwin described his voyage to Cape
Horn on the HMS Beagle in 1833 as a
pivotal moment in his life and key to
his theory of the origin of the species
the scenery here is still pristine but
as we prepared to pass the same Glacier
that Darwin himself must have observed
we are keenly aware of just how much and
how fast our natural world is changing
a decade ago this Glacier reached the
ocean but now it's melting fast
we arrive in Port Williams population
2000 where streets were paved only seven
years ago
it houses a Chilean Naval Base
government workers a small native yagan
community and king crab fisherman
things have improved a lot we've
recently got internet
but more change is on the way next door
a larger dock is being built to make
Port Williams a gateway to Antarctica
for cruise ships
yes the dock will bring us some of our
neighbors tourists but now we'll need a
bigger Airport
tourism is an option but not just any
tourism say climate experts who are
worried about preserving these tempered
forests home to five percent of the
planet's biodiversity
that's why conservationists are
promoting bird watching to inspire
people to protect vulnerable species
such as these large woodpeckers it's
called biophilia this was coined by Dr
EO Wilson from Harvard and it's that
every every human has an innate
connection and love of nature
birds are the first species to respond
to climate change so scientists are
conducting intense research in these sub
Antarctic forests they use almost
invisible Nets to capture migratory
birds and place a tiny GPS on their
wings also testing them for the spread
of diseases like bird flu
this concept emerges mainly from humans
altering our ecosystems by entering
habitats that were previously isolated
putting animals in contact with humans
which can spread diseases the Cape Horn
International Research Center based here
is also promoting biocultural education
betting it will help cement a new model
for sustainable development on our
planet's remaining unspoiled
environments an ambitious experiment
that could have a global impact
you see a Newman Al Jazeera Port
Williams Chile